okay so hltv have sounded their yearly
trumpets
unveiled the top 20 cs go players of
2020
and well it's official xaiwu was the
best player in the world
not simple the thing is this past
weekend we saw simple secure the first
big tournament victory of 2021
and clap xyboo along the way now does
that devalue
hltv's ranking of course not does it
make what is already the best rivalry in
esports
that much spicier [ __ ] yes
okay so before we get on with the video
i just want to let you guys know that if
you're interested in seeing
more edgy cs go don't at me's like this
please let me know in the comments and
of course subscribe to the channel
also if you enable notifications then
you can see
every single time a new video goes live
you may have also noticed that we are
a little more than halfway to two
million subs and i'd really like to see
us get to two million
before let's say simple oust xaiwu for
the number one spot of 2021.
all right back to the video okay so for
those who are unaware
every year for the better part of the
last decade hltv has ranked the top 20
counter-strike players in the world
and every year the community awaits that
list with
baited breath why because it matters
it's numbers driven fiercely analytical
and given how long the tradition's been
going on
quite prestigious only a handful of
competitors have ever had the
distinction of being in hltv number one
neo get right coldzera simple
and that beautiful rosy cheeked cherub
that is a zywoo so what is it that makes
zai wu's back to back number one
finishes
so ridonkulously impressive the fact
that he isn't
actually the goat though uh
he could have fooled me see for several
years now cs go's de facto greatest of
all time has been none other
than simple the ukrainian divinity who's
pretty much cemented himself as the most
famous professional first-person shooter
player
on the planet and with good reason
simple is
quite simply the most impossibly
talented player
ever to touch the game for years he's
regularly shown
that he can do things that shouldn't be
permissible by the laws of
counter-strike
that he's somehow tamed mastered or just
embodied the chaos that is cs the
desperate play
into b comes in smokes let's get double
smokes in the same place they're simple
just jumping casually into the side he's
gonna fall down and get out the door
what is this place from simple are you
serious what is that you can't do that
simple that's not allowed this is not
fpl this is a major
simple i i don't know man if he just
comes in with that
but i would say simple is a pretty good
example of someone who's very high on
the
quick to shoot skill and actually
sometimes you see him
with his crosshair placement not that
great what do you think
well why is he looking like this doesn't
look like how you would want
it to look considering he's the best
player in the world by the end of 2018
simple had secured his first ever hltv
number one and the consensus was that
despite not actually playing for the
team who won the most
it wasn't even close he was far and
above the best player in the world
and in most people's opinions in the
history of cs go
is he the best player ever to touch
counter-strike yeah for sure i would say
yes i think so
ever to play cs go yes he was the best
oper rifler diegler he could
clutch entry strategize and just
generally counter any and all efforts to
play
cs go against him it took him a couple
years but
lo and behold simple had solidified
himself
as pretty much the greatest to ever do
it for someone to come along and
dethrone him out of nowhere i mean that
just seemed impossible
and then zyru happened kill coming in
brawl and steps up
three kills to brawl that and zai will
eventually drop him on the floor but it
has to be the one before clutch from
zyward
need to come send barely enough health
to survive here on broadland but xavier
wants to kill there's the head shot
pulls it back there's the open side
who's got the triple
krimz is the last man standing and
there's time for the defuse
cyber wants to smoke the bomb if you're
crips you have to be scared
and silently wins it that is
unbelievable from the young frenchman
okay so zywoo's spark notes are as
follows
born on the very day of counter-strike's
retail release
this hyper-talented french prodigy is
healed for
years to be the savior of the long
floundering french scene
and the so-called chosen one of cs go
he makes his professional debut at the
end of 2018 and by early 2019
is not only the star player of team
vitality but
the only competitor in the world who
everyone agrees is actually capable of
rivaling simple participating banana
from the looks of the guy over here
that rings out first second he's had
enough he's gonna keep going through it
he doesn't really care about it
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like the universe saw how hard
simple was smurfing
got bored of watching him roll everyone
and
spat out zyewu just to spite him what
was it that made zai wu
so ridiculously absurd you ask
honestly it's kind of hard to explain he
wasn't a wild card like simple
on the contrary he played cold
calculating
surgical cs he just played it
perfectly it's like he's always two
steps ahead of his opponents
like like his brain has wall hacks
i don't know it's just annoying to play
against you know like whenever he gets
into a position where he where he has
after plump and anywhere he is on any
side like it's always annoying i feel
like he's more well-rounded
uh i feel like simple like often kind of
lets his teammates create space for him
but zyu creates his own space
and i think that's pretty impressive
saibu a lot of time i see him especially
in high pressure situations i i see him
he's got obviously a lot of flick but i
do see him sometimes
sort of reading the game at a what looks
to me like a slightly deeper level by
the end of 2019 he'd edged out simple to
secure the top spot on the hltv
top 20. for a rookie to take down
sasha the smasha in his first year of
play
it was incredible unthinkable the fact
that he was able to do it again
in 2020 is just i mean the kid's a
[ __ ] unicorn
an electronic looking for the cleanest
finish he's been turned on
die woo no health really but he's still
hitting shots he's already got three and
four and five
and oh my god zywoo
unbelievable practically godlike
now to be fair simple did hit back
hard in february of 2020 he led his
roster
navi to the most significant tournament
victory of the year
and put up one of the most staggering
mvp performances of his life
he needs a multi-kill first found twist
aggressing they have to double peak he's
getting his shots he's heading
simple oh simple that's unbelievable
what in his name number one in the game
he's done it again and then
right as if it was looking as if navi
were about to establish a
dynasty cove it happened
thus began the so-called online era of
counter-strike
one in which lands were non-existent
up-and-comers were king
and tier one rosters struggled to stay
on their a-game
unfortunately navi fell off a cliff
and remained coin flippy as hell for the
rest of the year now does all of this
mean that xaiwu has somehow
superseded simple as the colloquially
accepted greatest of all time
personally i think no not even close
not yet at least simple spent years
putting struggling rosters on his back
and pulling off
disgusting unthinkable [ __ ] with little
to no support
you can't just undo that in a year or
two what's more simple could
very easily have taken last year's top
spot
seriously it was even more of a toss-up
than in 2019.
unfortunately fanboys such as myself had
to watch as navi made a comeback
at the end of 2020 only to get reverse
swept
in not one but two grand finals
had they won even one of those events
especially the one they lost to zywoo
the top two could have shaken out
much differently as for who's better
right now
it's impossible to say just this weekend
we saw simple slap zyu in the semis of
blast
premiere where he managed to spearhead
his roster
to a sorely needed tournament victory
that's right the undertaker
and his team they get the better
of every single challenger sent into
that lower bracket
did simple get up to his usual nutty
antics you ask
brah simple on this passive angle down
in secret on the right side of this peak
glaive oh my god not ready for that one
simple's gonna stick around with just
the pistol
and then he goes back servings from
simple no scope from simple
and even further damage as for who
actually emerges as the best player of
2021
who can say what we do know is that
simple is keeping his nose to the
grindstone
since well he wants his goddamn spot
back
i'm not gonna have relax as i told
before i want to be
on this level for so many years and it's
great there are
a lot new players and players that can
play really really good because that's
exciting for me as well i'm
learning their game and i'm trying to
see something new for because of my game
all i know is that even as a die-hard
simple stan
i am here for this sick ass clash of the
titans-esque rivalry
dare i say not since flash and jaedong
has esports bore witness
to two certifiable gods battling it out
like this week after week
vying for ultimate supremacy i for one
can't wait to see how it pans out
i'm going to start a church you want to
start my church of simple highlights
devon
central the church of the undertaker
sasha the smasha
could be like your right hand alderman
yeah go
let's [ __ ] go bro you can you can
there's a i think at one point i had a
script someone cut it but i had it
there's a tab there's a there's a tab on
broken hub that literally just says
simples deagle
and you can click that and it's just
highlight clips from fpl did simple get
up to his usual
nuts antics you ask
brah